all right so through much reflection and
reading the suggestion in the comment
section so I appreciate that they talk
about spoilers from now on when I talk
about Mandalorian episodes because it's
a half an hour long episode it's kind of
hard to talk about it without talking
about what actually happened in the
episode so there's that you've been
warned and that's from here on talking
about the Mandalorian so we have a new
episode of the Mandalorian in which the
Mandalorian along with baby Yoda cuz
awesome he finds himself on this little
planet that's very out of the way
perfect to hide on heroes across someone
who used to be a member of the rebellion
now she's a mercenary and then they
fight they kick each other's asses and
then they're just like did we just
become best friends yep what is there's
this little town a village a camp a very
technologically inferior settlement of
people they keep getting raided by these
bandits and they're like can you help us
and he was like we'll help ya which
makes this episode of the Mandalorian
one of two things it's either an episode
of the a-team this is our first live
look at the Mandalorian without his
helmet or it's the movie star trek
insurrection crushed down to about a
half an hour long one of those two
probably both this is funny because it's
like Star Wars is taking cues from the
not good Star Trek movies and hate
insurrection I just I just felt like it
was it felt like a Star Trek episode
which I guess works because the
Mandalorian it is a TV show this is an
episode so I guess adapt the [ __ ] out of
it so they train the village people to
fight they make a trap and they throw
down and they fight off the bad guys and
that's the episode of the Mandalay team
but I was like does that ATSC doesn't
have a driver or is it just like this
thing with glowing eyes like sallekhana
it looked like a aia but i guess it has
someone in it in a world where you can
clearly see he walks in the eyepiece
windows so whatever was in there was too
short to be seen shorter than he walks
sure which the formula of the episode
set up
I feel like episodes like this it's like
it's a little more filler than I would
want the filler episode still serve as
good character episodes for the
Mandalorian himself he talked about how
he can't take off his helmet so he
doesn't take off his helmet around
anybody and you even see as the
opportunity to settle down in this
little place a very nice peaceful place
with him and baby Yoda and there's one
lady who saying he has a shot doesn't
quite cover it but even in the face of
that it's the story about how people
just tend to stick to what's familiar
it's like Knights that's not me though I
like that about this episode it was
it showed a little more about him but it
was really talking about us even by the
end of this it shows like they're
tracking baby Yoda
I guess because someone actually found
them they were gonna kill baby Yoda I
legit was like he's not gonna they're
not going to right but now the assassin
got taken out but it's like alright
they're tracking baby Yoda which means
the natural next episode is going to be
how are they tracking baby Yoda let's
find the tracker and let's take that out
but that is one adorable alien isn't he
alright last Jedi we got it we've heard
the chatter but what was trending on
Twitter what was hashtag besides that
dick pores cute [ __ ] baby cute [ __ ] four
days they know they're doing the baby
otter crushes porks it's not even a
contest so in the end my thoughts on
this episode were it was an entertaining
enough episode of the a-team it's like
an episodic episode like this I can roll
with better if we have 24 episodes of
season maybe 12 but when you're rolling
on eight you kind of need it all to be
core story and other than them finding
out Yoda is being tracked it did feel a
bit more filler than I would have liked
but episodes like this are why I like
binging shows that this is all done I'm
gonna go back and binge it all but I
like having the hardcore intense episode
alright the softer episode the hardcore
episode the softer episode just going
right through now that this episode
didn't have excitement but it's not like
it's not like last episode I did like
the character moments with the
Mandalorian so there that is and those
are my thoughts on Star Wars
insurrection versus the Mandalorian
episode for have you seen at what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]